こんにちは
[音楽]
始めちゃう僕が今まで様々な大食いはやくはやの一歩威嚇を彫らせていただいてきたん
だけども今まで正直一度もすごいキロを出したことあるん
そんな僕でもひょっとスタキョッとしたら最強の気力作れるのではない
どんなスバラスィ客を見つけてしまいましたこちら踊っている車間マックシェイクで
ございますし
て出してるでしょ私火吹いの穴党なんですそうこんなはとの僕であればずっと aiff
の狭間のようなそんな園バスで初見社員であればねこんな色ちょっと中途半端が肇社長
でもきっと最恐の記録が作れるんだよね
というわけで今日はバックチェックの早飲みで挑戦しようと思いますするにマック
シェイクエースなんですけども100
94g です結構多いですねってことは10個あれば今って多くない待ってもらって
また待ってくださいね危ないやこれにキロのみ不足だった死ぬ死ぬ
ズームリカ氏年で辞めていきますとりあえずシェイク s をご購読タイムを計ります
約1リットルです1リットル分午後こんな舞台も図りつつ
ずっこのれるかどうかの挑戦っていうもうあのへの1 o
3容量増えたコンテンツでやりますこれはまず実験ですねこちらの残基でもらうと思い
ます宜しくお願いしますあります
いきます良い母
[音楽]
吸引力も大事ですねこれなかなかいい
頭痛いうわこれうわぁああこれ後でいいかもしれんなあ元ません
[音楽]
ん
おおーー
中谷さんおおもうそんなにかかる
1分もかけませんやっちゃうかこれ何にもわかんなかった2つじゃねっため
やスタート地点でやりましょう公式ルールですね
2はつけてやりましょう
[音楽]
を
なぜか同じ高い山に米変わりました台風がです今3分ねちょっとこれあのお茶の間で
できないんで皆さんやるときは審査員のことをやってくださいあと制御をですねとげて
いるとそれシークではありません
シェイクの残り香でしっかりとカッター20分以内とか得るべくサブシェイク凍って
いる状態での調整が望ましいと思いますそこら辺皆さんご注意してぜひ挑戦してみて
くださ
1位
おーだー土産ねぇ
で時間4分ます
[音楽]
ぶっ
さあだぜこれあっはいください
[音楽]
いっ
はーはっはっは位
奥まで多いだそうですはい
5 up 1秒でございましたどうでした
するだけでちょっともう凍ってる世界ってやつみましょう関係で29歳一般なんだろ
タイマー8分ということでそれ上回られるの言葉ですねひどいではついては8
おぉっ
サドン
[音楽]
きますよねますよね最初
パー2ん
うーん断崖クルーズよ
[音楽]
5分終了ですいや遅いです
ん
んじょい混ぜば
25ありがとう
このように本目高くなってるって本当に行った1悪いこれで a 2
[音楽]
そういうところではたださーん
も用品です
ana
ません
犬あん
思想
[音楽]
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
まああとの痛いっ
[音楽]
ああ
ぬーん
大広く6分37秒7
増税者一さんはい
ああ
ギュルが冷たいん
me
うううう
uh
買ってみてくださいハッピーそれ行けそうと言ってガーッ
aak ホテルじゃ詰めたい一つ額ちょちょちょんねるずしっかり食べたい所
わー
するだけです交わすツリーすごい